Sorry, I didn't even have chat open.
We're just straight into it.
I was like, oh, fuck.
I was trying to decide if I want to use YouTube or Twitch quality.
And then I found out that Twitch quality is better and it's ahead of YouTube.
So I was like, that's fucked.
I was like, they should be at the same speed.
But the Twitch streams were ahead of the YouTube streams.
Which I was like, that's fucked.
Oh my god, I'm going to click that I'm live.
Sorry.
I don't even have chat open.
I'm a mess.
Oh my gosh, who cares?
I don't care what you're saying right now, Jeff.
I'm going to turn you down.
Nobody cares about where you...
Everybody's here for the trip.
No one cares.
No one cares what you're actually saying.
All right.
Oh shit, surprises.
Oh, I caught that.
Okay, let me...
I need a quote or a tweet and be like, live now.
Okay.
Live now.
There we go.
I'm a professional streamer.
Hello.
Guys, Jeff is talking.
You guys don't care what he's saying?
What do you mean?
Turn up the volume.
We don't...
I'll turn it up when he's not talking.
Chat.
You guys do not care about what he's saying.
Okay, now I'll turn it up.
Not actual gameplay.
Oh, 2K games.
I like how it says not actually gameplay.
That like makes me feel much more like, you know, it definitely reassures me a lot.
When it's...
No!
What?
Are you...
No way!
Are you fucking...
Okay, it's all right.
We're...
Everything is fine.
Okay.
I'm a mess.
Everything's okay.
The curse of...
Let's get...
Nothing important happened.
Okay.
Nothing important has happened so far.
The curse of Jeff.
All right.
Okay.
We're okay now.
Everything's fine now.
All right.
Is the volume a lot better now, guys?
I'm fine.
Oh, Borderlands?
Wait.
What?
Oh, right after the shitty movie?
That's awkward.
No!
Borderlands 4?
I mean, like...
Okay.
Not gonna lie.
This is so...
Yeah.
I was like...
This is so fucked.
Right after the very shitty movie that came out.
It's definitely a lot less hype now for me.
Borderlands 4 is coming in 2025.
Next up, October 25th.
Marks the release of...
Oh, my God.
Black Ops 6.
I feel like, you know...
It's a little awkward with the timing and everything.
Yeah.
Oh, this is so awkward.
I'm not as hyped because of the very bad movie.
They made a movie?
People have already, like, already, like, blocked it out of their mind.
Not a single cheer.
It features an all-new campaign with 16 new characters.
That's the new one.
Also, they've got new multiplayer maps with the return of classic prestige in theatre mode and two brand new zombies experiences on day one.
Oh.
Did they fix the problems with Call of Duty?
And War Zone gameplay at the Call of Duty Next event on August 28th.
But did you fix the issue?
Did you fix the issue...
No, day one.
Did they fix the security issue?
That's the thing.
Yeah.
Today, we're here representing the Raven team, who's leading the campaign in partnership with Treyarch.
The Black Ops 6 campaign is set in the early 90s...
Security issue?
Oh, like if you play Call of Duty, apparently it's very easy for hackers to get in.
You're joined by legendary characters Frank Woods, the Grizzled Vet, and Russell Adler, the Ultimate Wild Card.
Together with new allies Troy Marshall and Jane Harrow, and unbound by normal rules of engagement, you'll unravel a mind-bending conspiracy.
In the mission we're about to show you...
Wait, do people actually play Call of Duty for the lore?
I thought it was just war.
They're like, this mission's gonna be super interesting.
And I'm like, wait, people pay attention to the lore?
So we're gonna show up to this fundraiser, get what we need from the senator, then grab Adler...
Why do I sound so bored talking about- it's fucking Call of Duty!
Like, how- It's literally the same game rehashed six different times.
Not even six, it's been rehashed like, so many times.
They've like, literally ran out of war to make games about.
The senator isn't giving interviews tonight, and he doesn't go anywhere without his security detail.
I've marked a few leads that could help get you close enough to do the retinal scan.
Take your pick.
I got it on good authority that the senator's- Are we like, Indiana Jones-ing it now?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is this spy shit?
What?
Wait, are we hitmanning?
I've cleaned up another of your messes.
That was Bill Clinton?!
I couldn't even recognize him!
Oh shit, we ran out of war so we're going straight to CIA.
Snap!
That's going in my cringe compilation.
I modified the infrared image to highlight the capillaries in the senator's retina.
It should have just enough resolution.
What?
Oh!
It's like the scan-in.
What is this?
This is Call of Duty now?
Are we gonna kill the- Wait, I don't know if I can say that as a joke.
Like, even if we're a game.
I stopped myself.
I was like, I don't want to get bad.
Like, what- Are you serious?!
What?!
Are you- Okay!
Like, why are we at the- I'm so confused.
What is the plot?
This is so poorly timed.
This is- This is so poorly timed!
This game is- Oh my god!
The old man says you're worth it.
You better be right.
Sev, we got the prize.
Good.
Now get out.
Fine.
We've got party crushers up here.
Great.
You good to go?
I am now.
What the fuck?!
Is this where- That's where all the taxpayer's money went to.
Take cover!
For that one guy.
Yeah, I was like, what is this Fallout shit?
I don't think Pulitzer can hit him.
500 million- No, what- 500 billion dollars went into that one guy.
Each bullet cost $50,000.
And-
I actually sort of want to play the game just for the little baby cart.
The RC cart!
Yeah!
I- I sort of- I sort of want- I just like hit- I was like, what the f- Where did he pull that from?
Where did he-
The toy car destroys $5 billion guy.
This is a se- If it was a serious trailer, it would not show the fucking RC car.
I am- Wow!
I'm such a good person!
He's literally coughing baby, Bruce is hiding in the bomb.
Oh...
Let go.
Let him go would be so funny.
I know this is Call of Duty!
They're like inside a building!
It's like Call of Duty is supposed to be outside.
Oh there it is.
No this is still inside.
Oh my god that was Bill Clinton!
Wait what year is this?
This is legitimately a very poorly timed game.
Like...
If my like assumption on the plot is like...
That's boring Call of Duty.
America!
Fuck yeah!
Wait how's the sound so far?
Oh shit!
Wait that looks sick!
I fucking hate...
That looks sick and I don't have to drive the motorcycle while shooting.
That's my favorite part.
Yo this is America!
This is what people think...
Like outside of America think what America is like everyday.
The Illuminati!
They showed the fucking Illuminati!
Confirmed!
Illuminati confirmed!
August 30th!
Wait that's so close!
There you go Black Ops 6.
More coming at Call of Duty next.
That's actually so close.
My co-host for opening night live.
You know her from her years of hosting League of Legends eSports around the world.
Did you know that she got her start as a competitive Unreal Tournament player?
What?
Please join me in welcoming to ONL Shox!
Who?
Gamescom thank you for the warm welcome.
Unreal Tournament that is quite the throwback.
But I am so excited to be here tonight revealing many of the games on opening night live.
Wait if she's from Unreal Tournament then she's a hag.
Gamescom week in Cologne.
Gamescom really is the best week for games worldwide every year.
And I am so stoked to be back here with you all celebrating it.
Now it is my pleasure to share a message from Gamescom to you.
You can't see.
Why can't I see?
It's not negative.
I hope you visit wonderful places.
Oh that's a cute cosplay.
I bought the real blocks.
And that you always have the best adventures.
That you fight for the things you love.
And that you love the things you do.
Dear future me.
My favorite thing in the world is to play.
Do you like to play too?
Welcome to Gamescom.
We're there.
That's us.
Yes the future is here and we are ready to play.
Let's take a look at this fun trailer.
Wait I can't say that about Fleshtubers.
I thought hag was like a universal term.
I meant that like positively.
Positively.
Oh no I'm chronically online.
Oh no.
I'm chronically online.
What the fuck is this game?
What?
What is this game?
Yeah was he...
Wait what?
That's...
And then there's GTA.
Is that...
What?
What's that?
Love.
Hate.
Oh it's Goat Simulator.
It's Goat Simulator 3.
Isn't it?
It's Goat...
Yeah.
I fucking knew it.
Wait Goat...
Sorry Goat Simulator 4.
Or DLC.
Oh my god.
It's Goat Simulator 4.
The moment I saw...
Goat Simulator Remastered.
The moment I saw the goat I was like...
In my opinion that looked like the goat of all remasters.
Wait does she...
Is she one of the creators?
Okay.
Well...
We are expecting hundreds of thousands of fans at Gamescom this year in person.
But if you cannot be here with us, don't worry.
You can join us virtually by going to Gamescom Global where you can explore and discover what the world's gaming industry has in store for you.
And our very own Gamescom Studio is here with all day coverage of the event.
So tune in to Gamescom Studios broadcast by IGN on Tuesday.
On Twitch or on YouTube.
Now we have some news on Persona 3 Reload and its next DLC episode, The Answer.
Coming on September 10th.
It's time to reveal a surprising boss fight coming to the game.
Oh.
I mean...
Yay for the people who are into Persona.
...will be March 31st.
It's like Tartarus all over again.
There is a strong connection between all of you...
...and what's happening.
Let's do this.
Jokey processing.
Something's wrong.
I mean, it's Persona.
Oh, okay.
I guess no more dancing.
Alright.
Boo.
I wanted more Persona song.
Why did you cut it short?
Boo.
I was fucking jiving.
They stopped the banger.
What's this?
God, I wanna play Call of Duty 6 now because of the RC cart.
That shit was so funny.
Very poorly tied, but so funny.
With the RC cart.
The boy?
Oh, wait.
He sounds like...
He sounds like the Australian from The Boys.
What's this?
It can't be dying.
Like, there's not enough parkour.
Is it Predator?
The graphics look like shit, but like, it could be fun.
Is this a streamer game?
Oi, huiui.
Hahaha.
Oh, it's a game.
Oh.
Are you playing Power Rangers?
Pfft.
Oh, my gosh.
Are you playing Power Rangers?
Oh, shit.
Wait, it is dying light.
Oh, it is.
Oh, my gosh.
I was like, there's...
That can't be dying light.
There's no fucking parkour.
There's too many guns.
Dude, I don't see them.
The Beast.
Why the fuck did the opening look so, like... low quality?
The intro for that, I couldn't tell it was Dying Light.
The intro for that looked so, like, off.
That's why I was like, oh, it can't be Dying Light.
Black Mid?
Oh!
Wukong!
Yeah!
What?
The game's out?
Everybody's already playing it.
Like, by the way, I know, like, a lot of people are playing it right now.
Anyway, here's the launch trailer.
Noooo!
Spoilers!
I didn't watch... I only watched, like, one trailer.
Really?
Okay, apparently I, like, looked up the lore.
Apparently this game is a... I thought it was a Journey to the West.
I thought it was, like, a Journey to the West adaptation, but I was, like, really confused because I was like, Wait, this is, like... we're starting at the end of the Journey to the West, but we're going west again.
Anyway, so I was, like, reading the... it's basically... it's not really spoiler territory.
But, oh my god, I have to fight a guy with, like, eight arms?
Oh my god, that's a giant ass baby.
There's a baby.
I can be a fucking dog
That baby grew up that baby you beat up this is him in high school now this is him now oh
Oh my god, these characters look so sick anyway for those who were very confused being like oh my god.
What the fuck?
Oh Shit, that's way too many gods to beat up But like the wu-con game is actually a sequel to the journey to the West and we're trying to like free We're trying to free wu-con
Is that the sparkling Sparkling game
Like how Dragon Ball Z trailer right after wu-con Some wu-con and then some Goku yeah
This is a game with like a million characters right with like 30 plus Goku's There should be like a game mode in sparkling zero Where you can?
Fight with as men like we fight with as many Characters as possible like wrestling Like wrestling and then like you just put all the Goku's in one match and like a free-for-all You should be able to do a free-for-all with all Goku's
The Goku Royal Rumble The Goku Royal Rumble The Goku Royal Rumble The Goku Royal Rumble The Goku Royal Rumble What the fuck is this?
What the...
King of Meat?
Yeah, that's supposed to be Jeff.
What?
This looks like a mobile game.
It looks like the mobile game from those people with the icons where man is shouting.
That's what the graphics remind me of.
Yeah, it looks like from the creators of Clash of Clans.
God, they want to be Fall Guys so bad.
King of Meat!
Guys, it's on Amazon Games!
Wait, it's on fucking Amazon Games?
Holy shit, there's so many, like, versions of this.
Amazon Games, what the heck is Amazon Games?
That's a real thing?
What kind of games does Amazon Games have?
Oh!
Is he the son of Spielberg?
Alright, linked.
Banner.
Guys, welcome to ONL.
I'm very excited to share this game with the world.
Can you tell us a little bit about your studio, first of all?
Yeah, well, first off, it's totally surreal to be here right now.
We started the studio back in 2020, and the majority of us had come from the AAA side of the industry, and at the time, we were just thrilled to have our own game, our own IP, and we could never expect being on the stage tonight at the end of that run.
The vision for our studio started with the idea of dreaming big and building smart.
The concept for our first game, even early on, felt very unique and full of heart, and this helped us bring together a very passionate team of talented developers.
It's through their skill, dedication, and true love for the game that we're able to be here tonight, going way beyond where we saw before.
It does look very Hi-Fi Rush-esque.
By the way, Hi-Fi Rush got bought by PUBG, so they're back now.
The studio's back.
I thought it was funny that PUBG Studios bought Hi-Fi Rush.
I don't know if you've heard of it, but it's a game where you play with your friends, and you're going to take on the role as one of the last remaining humans on planet Earth.
Allying with a friendly bot faction, you're going to aim to take down the combat army, hellbent on organic destruction.
Players can play alone or with friends in this vibrant world of robots.
Or...
Sorry, I was looking at Twitch chat for, like, the stream itself, and someone was like, stare.
The guy was just looking straight ahead.
Guys, I'm still thinking about the RC cart.
That trailer really, like, implemented into my mind.
I'm still thinking about it.
I just really want to play Call of Duty.
Of course I'll fucking use that shit.
Guys, you know what would be really cool?
I bet you the RC cart is just going to be, like, one portion of the game.
Like, it's just going to be that one moment, and that's it.
I feel like... I feel like I'm getting fucking baited, too.
Like, just a five second thing.
Buying a $73 game for one RC cart.
Oh, it has fishing.
Fucking robot f- What do I do with robot fishes?
You can't eat that.
Do we just starve on this island?
What is the food here?
I was like, are they all just robots?
How do they survive?
Now, one of the things that I love about Gamescom is that it is a safe place for our diverse game fans.
And there is an amazing platform called Gamescom Cares that shares social and environmental responsibility projects that we care deeply about.
Thanks to all of our partners who help to make this happen.
You can learn more by scanning the QR code below.
And now, the first look at the gameplay of Lost Records, Bloom, and Rage.
A narrative adventure from the creative minds behind Life is Strange.
Oh, Life is Strange.
I've never played this game before.
But I remember, like, when it first came out, um, everyone was, like, screaming about it.
Honestly, Swan, I'm glad, but slightly surprised that you showed up tonight.
When I saw your text, all these memories came flooding back.
Yeah.
It was, like, a huge YouTuber meta.
I never even watched playthroughs.
Is she also gonna die, too?
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
Spoilers.
That's, like, literally the...
Sorry.
That's literally, like, the twist of...
Oh, yeah.
This is serious.
We're gonna need a real band name.
Bloom and Rage.
How could I forget?
Oh, guys.
What?
And they were roommates, by the way, guys.
My mom found a package on her doorstep.
Wait.
Are Bloom and Rage...
What?
Are we... in trouble?
Oh, this is not even Life is Strange.
It's just a spin-off.
Or not a spin-off.
It's just a whole new game.
Excuse me if today's sermon is a little...
Oh, yeah.
Definitely going to die.
What the fuck?
Today is not a normal Sunday.
Are we bringing back zombies again?
I wanted to...
Oh!
In our duty to God!
I can't wait for this game to be played for you.
For like one week by all streamers and then never again.
Oh, it's...
You're right!
It's almost Halloween!
It's zombie season again!
It's always either...
It's zombies or space.
Those are like...
Oh, no more room in Hell 2.
Alright.
That game looks great.
It's a new look at the eight-player co-op of No More Room in Hell 2 from Torn Banner up in Canada where there are deadly consequences of not...
There's still no more...
So, No More Room in Hell 1 was a lie.
It's been a long time coming for this next one.
At the Game Awards in 2021, Embark Studios revealed Ark Raiders, a game that immediately...
Not gonna lie, I'm also sort of low-key bored of zombies, too.
... future Earth where menacing Ark machines threaten humanity's attempts to rebuild.
Well, Ark Raiders has evolved a lot since then, and now it's finally time for some news on what's next for this exciting action survival shooter.
Survival...
I hear survival.
Look
at us now.
Raiders.
Oh, that's a gun I'd love to craft in my survival shooter.
Ark Raiders.
That's it.
Wait, what?
What's the gameplay?
What's the...
Okay.
Ba-dum, ba-dum.
Ba-ba-da-dum.
Oh
my god!
They're so cute!
Ba-da-dum.
Ba-dum, ba-dum.
Oh my god, it's so cute!
Is this like a Korean...
Korean game company?
Yuki.
Papa.
Love.
Peace.
Oh my god.
This looks all pre-rendered.
Infinity.
The coziest open world game.
Space Mary Warhammer!
It's coming out like next week, right?
Or the week after?
In two weeks.
What game company made Miki?
Ba-ba-ba.
Ba-ba.
Space Marine.
Play four days early?
Oh my god, there's so many good long playthrough series coming out.
I don't know if I should pre-order it though.
I don't know.
I'll go pre-order it early so I can stream it early.
But then I have like so many playthroughs.
It's made by Inful Games?
Ba-dum.
Wait, is this a...
Is this a hero shooter that people were saying looks bad?
Oh hey, Hanzo.
Oh no, this is not a hero shooter.
Is it?
It looks like PvPvE.
Drawing over 2 million players on beta?
Oh, it's Paragon?
It's MOBA?
It looks like now that you say it's MOBA, it looks like...
Sorry.
I guess the 2 million players was just a little too...
UI, like, trigger-coding it.
Predecessor.
Wait, is that...
Wait, that guy looks like...
Looks like Mortal Kombat, bro.
What you saw right there was Predecessor, a MOBA shooter built by an indie team from the ashes of Epic Games' Paranoia.
MOBA shooter.
From that way, it enters 1.0 free-to-play release tonight.
Next up, Path of Exile 2.
I don't want to get in trouble, but so many game companies are making MOBA shooters now.
And tonight, yes, we do have news on the early access date.
Check this out.
They're just trying to...
They're like, everybody likes MOBA.
People like shooters, too.
Let's combine both.
But what they don't know is that a lot of people who play shooters don't really like MOBAs.
And people who play MOBAs don't really like shooters.
It's like a very... I feel like it's like...
A very niche...
Like...
A very, very niche category.
Do you have the strength?
Build it anew.
I must.
Is this Path of Exile?
It should be, right?
It looks like it.
It can't be a new Diablo game.
They haven't milked it enough.
They have to milk it at a certain point until they...
And then they'll be like, alright, I will make a new game.
True.
Well, that looks absolutely great.
Can't wait for that one.
And now, Gamescom is known for the cosplay.
The vision and dedication...
Wait, really?
I thought Gamescom was known for the fucking game trailers.
Do you guys know Gamescom has like several other days where they stream other stuff, but no one really talks about it because people are just here for the game trip opening night?
I was like, wait, Gamescom has like more than... is more than just one stream?
I thought it was opening night and that's it.
Plus, the Gamescom event arena, that is where I am standing right now and all of you are.
It is the biggest and most elaborate stage at Gamescom, featuring not only opening night live, but additional live shows.
I find that out because I was looking up like, what time is Gamescom?
And then they're like, well, there's this and then there's that.
But the opening night is at this time.
And I was like, there's more than one stream?
There's multiple days?
The open world survival MMO.
And news on when it's going to be released.
Oh, Dune Awakening.
Yeah, it's an actual convention.
I didn't realize it was an actual convention.
The thing is, I watched Gamescoms.
Like, I did Gamescom WatchOn last year.
And it never registered to me that it was like an actual convention in Germany.
I was just like, oh, it's...
I was just like, game trailers.
As a nameless prisoner, sculpt your appearance, choose your background, and then crash into the planet.
It's Gamescom.
I don't know.
I thought the com sounded for communication.
I thought it was spelled with an M instead of an N.
I thought it was like, games communication.
Welcome to Arrakis.
The most dangerous planet in the universe.
Meet hundreds of other players in the vast online world.
What do you mean?
I can't read!
It literally ends with an M!
In this case, a spit dart rifle and a stillsuit for your help taking down territorial deserters.
Working with others will always increase your chance of staying alive.
Oh, this does look like an MMO.
The deserter base.
Climb to a vantage point.
And prepare for violence.
Your choice of weapons and abilities determines your strategy.
Swordmasters lead the charge into battle.
Literally.
Yeah, I know.
I was like, oh, it does look like it.
I like how he's not dodging.
He's just...
I just can't play!
He's just standing!
And he said W.
W, shit.
It's not selling me on the gameplay if he's just walk, forward, shoot.
He doesn't even move!
He hasn't even left S or D.
He literally just W.
Using a gun in Dune is crazy.
And it's apparently a shooter.
And then sell blueprints of your architectural wonders to other players.
Lead your group to become a guild.
On Arrakis...
I'm surprised they don't show a gameplay trailer for PC.
Because usually if it's an MMO, you know?
You want to advertise the PC portion, not the console.
God, this looks fucking hard to drive.
Game radio provides insight into key events happening across Arrakis.
People are like, that's not Dune!
Discover landmarks, wrecked ships, and desert testing stations.
Filled with forgotten technology.
Arrakis is a vast planet.
You can explore unique locations.
Uncover valuable resources.
And search for secrets amongst the shifting dunes.
Wouldn't it all just be sand?
I think my biggest issue is this is an MMO.
But exploring the planet is just mostly sand.
There's no diversity on biomes and stuff.
I guess there's that.
But there's also rocks!
To play politics, you need power.
And on Arrakis, spice is power.
In the deep desert, beyond the shield wall, hundreds of players scour the landscape.
Hunting for spice.
Every spice blow has the potential to become a heated battle.
With multiple guilds vying for the precious melange.
Even when it looks like defeat is inevitable.
Where's the sand worm?
Is that the sand worm?
Oh, is that it?
That seems overpowered as hell.
Time PC early 2025.
Wait, so the people on console can't even play this until much later?
Like, what's the point of showing- That's fucked.
You can't have a new game without the sand worm.
And the sand worm summoning begins- They're like- They're like, console release is much later.
Then why the fuck did it show us console controls?
And now, here is the reveal of a new game from Tarsier Studios.
The creators of Little Nightmares 1 and 2.
Oh!
Oh, I'm looking forward to this.
I like the Little Nightmares franchise.
It's a very good franchise.
I wonder if you can-
Like, I know it has co-op, but I feel like it really- I don't know.
I sort of want to play this single player, but I'm not sure yet.
Because I feel like- I feel definitely it'll be more immersive as, like, a single- Playing single player.
Because, like, when you're playing co-op, it gets- Gets a little silly.
We start getting a little silly.
Oh, shit.
I really do enjoy- Oh!
Re- Re- Re- Renimal?
Wait, it's not called Little Nightmares 3?
That was Re-Animal.
The next big entry in the cozy game genre.
Re-Animal.
Now, would you like to discover the secret contents of Gamescom and receive cool rewards?
Wait, it's not called Little Nightmares 3?
Well, meet Epi, the robot on our website RPG Gamescom Epics.
Prove your nerd know-how, solve tricky puzzles, win prizes, gather trading cards, digital trading cards, and jump from level to level until the final boss spawns.
Scan the QR code below and the adventure can begin.
Do you win anything for free?
Open world adventure.
Today, Genshin Impact.
is unveiling more about the sixth nation of Natalan, which will be released on August 28th.
And we also have some news about when the game will be coming to Xbox.
People still play on the Xbox?
But which one?
Xbox 3?
There's so many Xbox names.
Like, I already lost track.
Oh, that's a cute design.
Oh, my God.
Wait, she's so cute.
Wait, I actually really like her palette.
Her color palette is really cute.
I don't play Genshin, but I have to admit, they have some really good character designs.
Oh, shit.
Now it's Monster Hunter?
What the fuck?
Yeah, it's like Pokemon Monster Hunter now.
There you go.
Jeff, are you okay?
You're like, Jeff, the camera's on, Jeff.
Jeff, the camera's on.
Here at Gamescom, Capcom has an incredible booth.
But now, to tell us more and show us more, please welcome to the Gamescom ONL stage, Ryozo Tujimoto from Capcom.
Ryozo-san.
Oh, Monster Hunter.
Speaking of Monster Hunter.
Here's Monster Hunter.
Not gonna lie, I don't know if it's just because, like, I don't know.
A lot of the releases they've shown so far, other than, like, RC car.
I've been, like, mega, like...
Ryozo-San, King of the Night Lights 8.
I've got to share my new Monster Hunter Worlds trailer with everyone.
I mean,
like, their hype released, they're hype, they opened with Borderlands 4.
But it's so awkward, because, like, everybody is, like, trashing Borderlands right now.
I get so...
So, like, the hype for...
I feel like if, you know, the movie never came out, people would be, like, more excited.
The 3 sucked too.
I mean, the Tales of Borderlands was pretty decent from what I've heard.
Uh, the Telltale series.
Borderlands 3 is such a bad game.
Okay, like, I told you guys, my experience with Borderlands 3, I've only played it, like, once, but, like, um, with friends.
And the thing is, the- my friends were already so high leveled and, like, that I couldn't even, like, play the game.
I was just being dragged.
Like, I- they're like, yeah, you should join us.
And then I was just- I was just there.
Like, I couldn't even shoot my gun because I would get slapped and then I'd die.
They would sneeze on me and I'd be fucking dead.
Like...
So, like, I never- I never got to actually experience Borderlands 3.
Yeah, they didn't start new characters.
They were just like, all right, let me- let's get you, like, the best guns.
And I was just like, okay.
I feel like- what was it?
I remember they had the- what was it called?
The Tina...
Tiny Tina's whatever.
I heard that one wasn't good too.
Anebex Predator?
Is he top 750?
Tiny Tina Wonderlands?
It was great?
Oh, it was?
I feel like I didn't see a lot of people play that game.
I like how it's like, Wonderlands was good IMO and then someone right below him was like, Wonderlands was bad!
All right, so it was mixed reviews.
I see.
So it was mixed reviews.
It was a good DLC but terrible standalone game.
Oh!
My favorite part.
The cooking.
And the cats.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay.
I was like- I was like, Tomb Raider?
But I was like, that's not Tomb Raider graphics.
Oh, I see.
I was like, Tomb Raider?
But I was like, that's not Tomb Raider graphics.
Destiny.
Everything lost.
I wish Naraka was...
...is meant to be found.
I wish Naraka was popular in the West.
It's so dead in the West.
But I heard it has a good player base in Asia.
Naraka is basically like melee battle royale.
A little taste of Shiranui Fire?
Woah!
Whoa.
Whoa!
Okay.
The camera!
I was not expecting the camera angles.
Oh, but it's not on Amazon games, so what's the point?
What's the point?
It's not on Amazon games, guys!
It's a publisher, not a storefront, but then, one of the games advertised to Amazon games, and you could get it there!
What's this?
This is Mecha, right?
I hope this game doesn't die like Gundam Evolution.
Too soon, Toki!
I never got to try out... the sad thing is I never got to try out Gundam EVO, because there's so many rules when it came to streaming it, and I couldn't be bothered at that point.
Exciting for fans of Monument Valley, the beautiful twisted puzzle game that we all played about a decade ago, when it was first released in 2014.
Well tonight, we are revealing Monument Valley 3, coming later this year from Us 2 in London and Netflix Games.
I played this, it is an absolutely beautiful, stunning game.
And we've got your first look right now.
What is this?
Monument Valley?
That's a cute game I'll never play.
I know what my place is, and that seems like a lot of puzzles.
I know it'll definitely fit others.
Others would enjoy it, but for me, my Oonga-Bonga brain, don't think I can solve this...
Bring to Monkye.
I've returned to Monkye.
By the way, if you guys didn't see, I am streaming... Oh my god, big fish!
I'm streaming Wukong tomorrow and Saturday.
Today is Monkye week.
We're returning to Monkye.
Oh, Netflix games!
Now, first released in 1991, Civilization is one of the gaming industry's biggest franchises.
And here at Gamescom, we are revealing the gameplay of Civilization 7 for the first time.
You know what's great about that?
That means Civ is not going to be on sale.
Civ 6 is going to be on sale soon.
But I already bought Civ 6.
I believe that it's been almost eight years since Fraxis released our last Civilization game.
So we're incredibly honored to be here tonight at Gamescom talking about Civilization 7.
Yeah, but that means they're going to be even cheaper.
Civ 7 is by far the biggest, most ambitious game Fraxis has ever made.
Oh god.
You shouldn't say that.
Because what if it sucks?
No, you're going to put too much expectations now!
What if it sucks?
Please join us after opening night live on the Fraxis Game Twitch channel for our official gameplay showcase.
Go to our Twitch channel.
Where we'll deep dive into what's new in Civ 7 and finally reveal our new in-game narrator.
On behalf of the team at Fraxis Games, who has worked so hard on this game, I'm so excited to finally give the world...
Bro, he's self-promoting his own channel?
Sid Meier's Civilization 7.
Follow my Twitch channel.
I respect the hustle.
Oh, I would.
I would definitely do the same.
I was just surprised that he did it.
Somebody in chat is like, where is Silksong?
Bro, stop.
Give up in the dream.
The dream's dead.
Accept it.
You're all in denial.
Jeff said there's no Silksong.
I love whenever Jeff was like, there's going to be no Kingdom Hearts news.
And then people were like, he's lying!
And then Jeff said again, there's no Silksong news.
He's lying!
This is definitely where he's lying for real.
And there was no Kingdom Hearts news.
What's the new part?
I couldn't tell.
It just looked like Sid.
Ever since we first reached for the stars.
That's the secret, Ducky.
We've been asking ourselves.
Oh, space.
What else is out there?
And more importantly, can.
Starfield?
Drive on it.
Is it Starfield?
Wait!
There he is!
Bam bam bam bam.
Bam bam bam.
Oh
my god.
My God.
R.C.
car.
Electric tooloo.
Is that the beach?
Wait, I can go to the beach in space?
Meow.
Especially when you're juicy.
AN adore it.
Just a fucking... Yeah, but it's a cool car.
You don't understand.
And it's free.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god, this car comes with fucking trauma.
It's parents.
This car's parents died.
Tonight at ONL, we're revealing two new heroes who are joining the game with a first look at their gameplay.
New more heroes?
I wonder how many heroes it's gonna be on launch.
I mean, they added a shark in there.
Wait,
what?
No way!
Bucky and Captain America?
Oh my god, I hope they add Hawkeye so he can get his shit beat.
Wait, does that mean all the Avengers are gonna show up too?
I hope they add Hawkeye so he can be like the Hanzo of Marvel Rivals, but he's just a regular guy.
Oh, he's a tank.
Okay.
Is Captain America a tank?
What the?
Wait, what is he?
What the fuck?
Okay, that looks overpowered.
That looks so overpowered.
Wait, what?
Alright.
Bucky and Captain...
Well, they must add the rest of the Avengers, right?
So we're missing, like, Hawkeye and Black Widow.
I'm sure everyone who played the beta wanted to know Marvel Rivals will launch on December 6th, 2024.
Now, Gamescom always strives to help the environment and the event runs on 100% renewable energy and is climate friendly thanks to ongoing measures to reduce I want Hawkeye to join just for just to have people be mad at Hanzo mains again.
Hanzo mains will...
Every game will have a Hanzo main.
And yes, fans are planting more and more trees in the Gamescom forest.
The forest has been growing since...
We're also missing a sniper.
We're missing an actual sniper, too.
Of course, you can plant your tree in the Gamescom forest today.
And with that, it is time to...
Yeah, every game needs a Hanzo.
This award celebrates an organization in the global game industry committed to sustainability and the environment.
Presenting the award, please welcome back Lisa Pak with Playing for the Planet.
What the...
I was like, did my PC do I have something playing?
Because the music played while she was talking.
Thank you for having me here.
It's an absolute pleasure, Lisa.
And in case some people don't know and need a quick refresher, Lisa represents Playing for the Planet, an alliance of gaming organizations committed to taking climate action under the official umbrella of the United Nations.
So how are things, Lisa?
Things are going great, thank you.
With 3.3 billion people around the world playing video games, we encourage everyone to make a difference wherever possible.
Absolutely, and 3.3 billion players is so, so much.
So do you have any tips for our players on supporting this great initiative?
Yes, definitely.
It's as easy as remembering to set up energy saving modes to avoid unnecessary energy consumption.
Or switching to renewable energy...
I was thinking, I was like, why is video games connected to the environment?
Because I'm pretty sure we're using so much energy and carbon footprint and everything so I felt like that was counterintuitive and then they're like, remember to play an energy saving mode.
I don't know.
The amount of energy I'm fucking generating.
And turning it into emission reductions demands a clear and actionable plan as well as collaboration.
And this year's winner has proven that it's possible to deliver ambition with execution across the board.
And this year's winner of the Gamescom Sustainability Award is Tencent Games.
And here to accept the award is Brent Irvine, the Vice Chairman of Tencent Games.
What did they win?
Well, first of all, let me say on behalf of Tencent Games how honored we are to receive this award.
Tencent Games encompasses a lot of things.
Everything from in-house studios like Timmy, global studios like Shark Mob, to our global publishing arm, Level Infinite.
What they all share is a commitment to operating our business in a sustainable way.
We are committed to carbon neutrality by 2030 and really want to thank all of our studios, all of our partners, but most of all, all of our players whose support is essential in helping us drive our efforts to have positive change within the industry.
Thanks again and back to the games.
Congratulations Tencent and Brent Irvine!
I'm so confused with this segment.
Because it's like...
I don't know.
Playing video games is not really about like...
Is it fuck to say playing video games is not really about saving the environment?
Is that...
There's just no correlation in a way.
Doki hates the environment.
I just didn't see like...
There being like a matchup.
That's why I was like so confused with the segment.
We do this because we fucking love video games.
Oh, he's gonna cry!
He fucking loves video games.
And every time a trailer comes online, And every time a trailer comes online, we see hundreds and hundreds of comments from the fans.
Like, why don't we see a movie like this?
Or why can't we have a series like this?
And we could not agree more.
Which is why we are so excited to share this series with you.
Fifteen original episodes created in collaboration with Amazon Studios and the publishers and developers of some of the world's greatest games.
I'm talking new titles, existing games, indies, and classics.
So, we've been working on this show for three years.
Which one is this?
Choked up, sorry.
I cry a lot.
He's passionate.
Alright.
We've been working on it for three years.
Oh, I hope it's good because I feel really bad if people review Bomb It after the fucking passion he gave.
He literally cried for it.
I hope it's good now.
For his sake.
It is our love letter to games.
And you can watch the series on Amazon Prime Video on December 10th.
Not too far now.
So, enjoy.
Thank you.
Wait.
It's a new series.
Wait, is this Warhammer?
Brothers!
It's time.
This world has waited for your arrival.
Is this an anthology?
From the visionaries behind Love, Death...
Oh, is this an anthology?
Of like different video games?
It is you.
Oh, I think it is.
You are the chosen.
Oh, that looks so sick.
Moments.
Okay.
I'm gonna say it.
Love, Death, Robots season 1 and 2 were pretty good.
Wait.
How many seasons does Love, Death, Robots?
Season 1 was really good.
And then the later season started getting a little bit eh.
So I hope like...
I think like if it's the first season it will be really good.
Because I love the first season of Love, Death, Robots.
This looks so...
Oh my Spelunky!
Oh wait!
Did you...
There's Spelunky!
I
can't believe it.
Yeah, there's our record.
Try not to disappoint us.
Oh no.
Why did they have to show this trailer right after?
Oh...
This looks like...
I feel bad.
If it wasn't...
If it did not come after the other trailer, this shit might look a lot better.
Is this Age of...
Age of Empires?
Age of Mythology?
Is this a remaster?
That's awkward for them to come after.
Yeah.
This is so awkward.
I feel like if this game was like not right after the trailer we just got, I feel like people would be more hyped.
But now there's like comparison between like the graphics and stuff.
Yeah.
This is Age of Empires slash Age of Mythology.
I remember we used to play Age of Mythology too.
I enjoyed it.
I hope they don't fuck it up like the World of Warcraft RTS game.
To be fair, it's not Blizzard so I say as I'm gonna be streaming Overwatch later today.
You know what I want a remaster of for RTS?
The Lord of the Rings one.
I used to play that shit all the time.
The Lord of the Rings RTS was so fun back then.
I used to play that all the time.
Like every day when it first came out.
And I had all the expansion packs too.
Was it Battle for Middle Earth?
I don't remember the title but I never got a remaster and I was so sad.
I've always wanted a remaster or just a port of it.
Yeah.
Battle for Middle Earth 1 and 2.
It was so fucking good.
I love the story missions.
The campaign and the individuals too.
And you know damn well I was only playing the bad guys.
The elves weren't that fun.
The elves and the humans weren't as fun as the bad guys.
They had such cool like really cool units.
Yeah.
I like the the um...
And then you get to have like dragons flying around too.
I did not pay attention to this trailer.
I did not pay attention to that game.
I have no idea what that game was.
It looked so generic that like my mind just tuned it out.
Oh this is the trailer where like the insurgents like medieval banging in the middle of it.
And then it like caught me off guard.
From the last like what was it?
From the Game Awards?
Or the Summer Game Fest?
Yeah.
Like we watched this trailer for this game.
For Summer Game Fest.
And then there was like medieval banging in the middle of it.
And I was like what the fuck?
Henry's just like okay.
I remember.
That's what they... I hope that's what they did.
That's how we have babies.
Yes babies do not come from storks I'm afraid.
They're not brought by big ass birds.
I'm sorry guys.
I could break it to you.
What?
But what about the animated storks movie?
I love how that movie is getting popular because of the who would win.
All the Pokemon in the world are like one million lions.
And then they're like the lions could be like that wolf pack from the storks movie.
Wolf pack make a play.
And now we've got the debut of a brand new area of new eridu.
Check it out.
It's a billion lions.
It's a lot of lions.
Okay.
And then like the argument for Pokemon was that if we're talking about variations there is like four billion Spinda variations.
So like...
I love that.
I was like...
Nerds!
Is that a rat?
Is that a rat girl?
I'm not surprised.
I heard their shark girl was so popular.
I always say this but I always feel like especially for like um like character designs if you make it like an animal girl it's gonna be super popular.
Wait.
Why did mom let you have three Hoyo verse ads?
How much money did they give Jeff?
Holy shit.
Is this Honkai Staria?
Probably a lot.
True.
They make a lot.
It's gacha.
This is like...
If you guys don't know this is why gacha companies sponsor so many things and people.
Because all they...
It doesn't matter.
Since they're a gacha game it doesn't matter if they have one person playing the game.
They sold the game to one person from these ads.
Because that one person is gonna spend so much money on gacha alone.
Yeah.
One will is all they need.
It's similar with like I told you guys before.
It's similar with like gambling sponsors.
I know how much they pay.
They never reached out to me but I have friends who have... who were reached out by gambling sponsors.
And it is an absurd amount.
Because all they need is to hook one person.
It's like...
I'll just say it's like...
It's an amount of money that you just be like holy fuck.
Like if you get sponsored by a gambling like gambling game or like company like casino or whatever.
Like you're literally one stream like one sponsor from them.
You're set for life.
You don't have to stream anymore.
... has done an incredible job bringing the world and combat into VR.
And here is your first look at the actual gameplay.
A gameplay trailer for Batman Arkham Shadow.
...
Oh is this a VR game that everyone is sad about?
Why does the graphic look...
...
I don't even... I want this to stay in VR because this graphics look...
I'm pretty sure in VR you wouldn't care about it though because you are here to be Batman.
...
Oh God that looks so tiring.
You know because like Batman you need to punch right?
You can't shoot anything.
I'm just thinking this is going to be...
This could be a workout.
Yeah, it looks like a workout.
Oh god, this definitely looks like a workout.
Ha ha ha, the punching.
Whoa.
Rats.
Become the knight.
It makes me wonder though, like, will they even have a lot of people?
Because it's like, VR is... oh my god, I forgot it's on fucking MetaQuest.
BOOOOM!
Fucking BOOOOM!
Fuck you, Facebook.
I was like, I thought about it.
I was like, oh yeah, maybe I should try it out.
I was like, oh yeah, I forgot it was on MetaQuest.
God fucking damn it.
Zuckerberg.
On both days with another 100,000 guests.
Now if you haven't been there yet, you should definitely go and check it out.
That is what's happening in Cologne and also people from more than 100 countries are here.
But, Gamescom has fans all over the world and I have good news.
Gamescom is heading to other continents!
The first Gamescom Latam took place in June and exceeded all of our expectations with over 100,000 fans immersed in the gaming universe.
It was a fantastic show and next year it's going to be even bigger.
Oh hey, Sao Paio!
Gamescom Asia returns this October.
You can join in on the fun and entertainment area to find out all about the games, the stages, the prospects, and much, much more.
Gamescom was not directed at me.
Why are you doing this?
Gamescom is back on the air on October 17th!
Now, who is ready for another world premiere!
Wait what about NA?
What about NA?
Stop wait!!
Little Nightmares!
I thought Re-Animal was Little Nightmares but like, re-branded into a new title.
So I guess they're making two games?
This is New Dez?
Oh...
Now I'm scared.
Okay, this is a little bit of a hot take.
But I saw Re-Animal first.
And the trailer first for it.
And Re-Animal looks so good.
Compared to Little Nightmares 3.
So I'm a little worried.
I'm just a little worried.
Are we gonna eat these cows?
Wouldn't it be funny to bring them all the way to whatever land?
And then we just eat them?
Because we're a shepherd, right?
A doggy?
What?
It's a herding simulator.
Where the fuck am I herding?
You think when we herd the sheep, we're not gonna eat them later?
That's the whole point of herding.
I mean, for the wool and the meat, right?
Oh, did you guys know?
Um...
Wool doesn't make you that much money anymore.
I don't know if it's true, like, if it's updated.
But I read that, like, wool doesn't make you as much money anymore as it used to be.
So people don't usually own sheep for wool.
And tonight, he's here to reveal...
Yeah, the wool meta fell off, guys.
It's the meat meta.
Please join me, Gamescom, in welcoming to ONL Peter Molyneux.
He's back!
What an incredible honor it is to be here on the stage with Jeff.
Yes, Peter.
He's an amazing man.
This is so fun.
So a couple months ago, you and I had lunch in London.
I was like, what are you working on?
You're like, well, I've actually been working on a game for a number of years.
You've kept very quiet about it.
I really wanted to, like, the game speak for itself.
But tell us about Masters of Albion.
Right, so...
I love that people's first message is like, don't believe this man!
There's so many first messages where everyone's like, he's lying!
Believe his lies!
This is the very first message on the stream.
To your credit, you've self-funded this project yourself.
You put together a team of a lot of veterans from those games.
Yeah, I mean, I think my first realization is I needed to bring the old team back together again.
So I'm working with people like Mark Healy...
Oh, tell me lies.
Tell me sweet little lies.
...and created Black and White Dungeon Keeper and Fable.
Anyway, let's have a look at Masters of Albion.
Alright, here's the world premiere, Masters of Albion, from Peter Molyneux.
This is Masters of Albion.
We're a team of 20 people dedicated to making something new, unique, and different.
Indian footage...
Oh yeah, it does.
Yeah, oh, mmm...
Okay...
This is Oak Ridge.
Gaining resources and earning money.
By night, your town will be attacked by many of Albion's creatures.
You can design anything...
Tap here to begin Chapter 2.
...where the weapons they use...
There is a strategy behind every creation.
Oh, Peter, why did you show it?
Oh...
I can help out.
The Sandwich Building Simulator was...
Oh, fucking...
I can also design, customize, and create all buildings.
It's the Colony Simulator game.
The sun is going down, and now my town needs defending against the horrors of Albion.
And this is my hero's time to shine.
At any point, you can possess a character.
Oh...
Okay...
My hero is now under my complete control.
And now it's time to fight.
Oh...
I don't think I want to be in this mode.
Let's switch back to god mode and unleash some real power.
I don't think I want to be in third-person mode.
That doesn't seem that fun.
I'm not gonna lie.
The third-person mode looks so fucking boring.
Compared to, like, god mode.
But bread swords just won't cut it.
Oh, shit.
This is just a glimpse of Masters of Albion.
An open-world god game full of combat, choices, mystery, and...
I guess the god simulator part seems fun.
But, like...
Oh...
Management offers a reminder.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Is this why Crab Game is, like...
There's no resources in Crab Game now?
How does Crab Game graphics look better than this?
I don't understand.
Crab Game was made by two guys.
Oh, one game.
Oh.
Mobile.
Of course it is.
Of course it is!
We all have phones, guys.
What's this?
What?
You slept there?
What game is this?
It can't be Witcher.
There's guns.
This has to be a new IP.
Right?
Forsaken?
I mean, it does look, like, Forsaken a little bit.
My journey.
Oh!
Unknown 9 Awakening.
Yes, really soon.
Is this the first time this showed up?
I don't think I've ever heard of it until now.
Wait, is this the Paedo and Tarkov?
You know what I thought was so funny?
The whole controversy with the Tarkov thing.
But like, they're still doing okay.
There's just nothing like Tarkov.
People can't quit.
We can't help them.
There's no saving.
Guys, there's no saving.
There's no saving Tarkov players.
Arena Breakout Infinite is now available in early access with the full release coming at the end of the year.
Now, over the years, Blizzard has been a big part of Gamescom history.
And this week, we are thrilled to welcome them back for the first time since 2019.
Here's the president of Blizzard, Johanna Fierce.
Wait, what?
Blizzard makes video games?
What?
Hello, hello, hello.
Welcome to Gamescom.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for having us on behalf of Blizzard.
This is such a massive moment.
But it's such a special time to be sharing it here with everyone at Gamescom.
And we're just really honored to be here.
Wait, what?
Well, we're very glad to have you guys back.
And I know you got a big booth with Xbox, right?
We do.
Yes.
And come on by if you're here all week long.
We're proud of it.
But it's also a particularly big moment for Warcraft.
We have celebrations and anniversaries galore across Hearthstone, across Rumble.
Jesus.
And of course, a very big milestone for Warcraft.
Twenty, thirty years.
Yes.
Speaking of World of Warcraft, the War Within, its global launch is coming up very soon this month, right?
Yes, it is.
And we're just days away from the global launch of the War Within.
August 26th, it's go time for that.
And in two days, we're going to be back.
In two days, we'll actually open up early access for players.
So we're psyched about it.
Come on in and join.
And I just want to say it's masterful work from the team.
The World Soul Saga opens up...
Are they still subscription-based?
...arguably some of the most ambitious we've ever seen since WoW initially released twenty years ago.
Damn.
And we can't wait to embark on it.
I wonder how much someone has paid for thirty years of Warcraft.
This month is time for that.
But I know this is, you said, there's so many Warcraft anniversaries, Blizzard anniversaries, Warcraft anniversaries.
How can players be a part of this?
Yeah, there's a ton of ways we're going to be able to celebrate.
So we definitely hope that you join us.
There will be in-game events...
Don't ask that, Toki!
I'm just like thinking, like, that's a lot of years.
That's a lot of hours, a lot of years, a lot of expansion packs.
So I'm just like, like, how much did this person pay?
...for our very first Warcraft Direct, where the team will share more in the coming months on all the things going on for the Warcraft universe.
Okay, well, that's exciting.
Now, I was wondering about, you know, all the other Blizzard teams, are they going to get in and celebrate these anniversaries, too?
They are.
There'll be some nice surprises along the way.
Wait, this is it?
Are you just going to talk about Warcraft?
They've been doing some amazing work, so they're honoring a world of Warcraft and the legacy that it brings.
I lied.
There'll be a new collab in September.
I lied, guys.
They don't, they don't make games.
So they're honoring a world of Warcraft and the legacy that it brings.
This is the first new skin.
It's Widowmaker.
Yay.
Embracing her allegiance for the Lord.
They don't even have BlizzCon anymore.
Okay, thanks for bringing a little scoop along with you.
That's fantastic.
Now, let's move to another franchise that has a big year.
Diablo.
Oh, yes.
All eyes on October 8th, yes.
We are super excited for the Vessel of Hatred, and we're even more excited that Diablo is here at Gamescom this week.
We'll be the chance to have the first ever live hands-on experience.
Oh, there's the milking.
There it is.
Remember when I said...
Guys, remember when I said they haven't finished milking?
It's going to be a key part of what makes the Vessel of Hatred so special for us.
All right.
Well, I understand you might have brought a little something.
That one guy that was like, whoo!
We have.
Here's a look at our mercenary companions.
So take a look on behalf of the Vessel of Hatred.
All right, guys.
We're back.
All right.
here.
For Tome of Valor.
Yeah!
All right.
Ready to stand and fight for those who seek us out.
My shield is your protection.
There was a time we fought the vilest of sanctuary.
You fools get uglier and uglier.
Until we were met with only our inner demons.
I miss when Blizzard made like cinematics.
Their hatred has pulled us back into the light.
Await
watching from the shadows.
Honestly, Blizzard could be a very good like animation company in general.
They just stop making games and focus on animation.
Their cinematics were so fucking good.
I've always loved their cinematics.
I
am your guardian.
I am your redemption.
I am your vengeance.
I am your rage.
That's a lot of new characters.
I like the little devil kid.
I am Batman.
The devil kid seems fun to play.
That looks great.
Thanks for the sneak peek.
Of course, and it's my esteemed pleasure to introduce Brent Gibson, game director of Diablo 4, Vessel of Hatred.
Hello, Gamescom!
The team and I are...
Where the fuck did I go use the bathroom?
The outlaw board of the first game that has something to all games.
An investment of hatred?
No, there's... it's almost too young.
We are hard at work and have new ways to play and new ways to grow in power.
That looks like the Blizzard panel is where I decided to use the bathroom.
Oh my god.
The fight alongside you in your battle against hell.
We're also adding...
Oh no, I can...
Persevere, Doki.
That gives you the control on the types of challenges you're gonna see, as well as the rewards you may get.
And we also have the Dark Citadel.
Our brand new co-op...
Yay.
That challenges everything you know about combat in Diablo through a gauntlet of multiplayer puzzles and mechanics.
We're talking about all of it right here at Gamescom.
And so stay tuned if you want to see all the things that you're gonna see in Vessel of Hatred launching October 8th.
They're like, please don't play Path of Exile.
And I hope to see every single one of you on the floor all the way through the show.
So thank you very much.
See you on the floor.
That's why Blizzard came back.
Because they're like, oh no, they're announcing Path of Exile 2.
We gotta come back.
The first Berserker Kazan set for 2025 release.
Intense combat meets breathtaking 3D cell animation.
In a brutal world from Nexon.
Coming to PC and console.
Let's witness the chaos that awaits.
Aww.
There's two wolves inside me.
Tear into the neck of the aged lion.
For years, I faced unrelenting fury.
Made countless sacrifices.
What is this?
Does he have the two wolves inside him?
I like the style though.
The cell shading on 3D models.
It's pretty neat.
Doesn't look too bad.
They were saying Nexon, but like...
Which is the part...
What should I be disappointed about later?
It looks really good.
Our alliance has been formed.
The first Berserker.
I fell for this trap so many times.
Oh, is this...
Is this...
Is this what I have to do?
The fact is I was like no.
Don't fall for it.
You didn't know what it was that it always wanted.
You're choices will remake the world.
And every turn becomes an opportunity.
Not gonna lie.
Those backgrounds look so AI generated.
So I hope it's not.
Like the tears in the back.
Alright!
I was like, he looks so AI-generated when they're sitting on those chairs.
What
the fuck is this?
Dog!
Oh, Darken Darker!
Oh shit!
Oh, mobile!
Oh...
Darken Darker mobile is now available for global pre-registration.
Now from NetEase Games, this next trailer is a new life simulation game where players can travel among super-powered worlds to craft their island and engage with friends.
I feel like that has been the most budget they've ever spent on a trailer.
For Darken Darker.
Because I was so confused.
I was like, wow.
What's this?
Awww.
Is this like Animal Crossing?
Awww!
Look at those little birds!
They're wearing little outfits!
Oh shit!
Changed the weather.
Yeah, who the fuck wants a thunderstorm?
That's so cute!
Oh, it's a farm game.
It's a farm game.
Oh, no, there's terraforming.
Oh god, I can't do that.
Just give me...
I can't terraform for shit.
You know like when Animal Crossing gave me the option to terraform, I stopped playing the game.
I was like, I can't.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I felt way too overwhelmed after that.
Oh shit.
The autumn and snow globes?
It's cute.
Coming.
More imagination sores.
Does anyone remember?
You know the style remember?
Remember that game about like the children with like...
It was like...
Looked like Splatoon, but like not really.
Indiana Jones and the Great Circle!
Oh!
I'm looking for this game.
It was like...
It was like these children with like Pokemon and stuff, but also Splatoon.
I can't remember what it was called.
Does it exist?
It had a really cute trailer, and then nothing ever came out of it.
It's up to you to uncover.
No, it's not the foam one.
They were like on skateboards and stuff.
Oh, Troy Baker!
It's humbling playing a character that so many people, myself included, look up to.
As a kid, seeing Indiana Jones in the theater for the first time was a defining moment for me.
And I never would have guessed that all these years later I would be the one wearing the hat.
But here I am.
It's been a dream come true.
A dream that I cannot wait for you to live for yourself.
The beauty of a first person game like this is that we all get to feel what it's like to become Indy.
You are the one who cracks the wind.
Who feels the weight of every punch.
And the thrill of finding every clue.
Indy is such a unique character.
Professor.
An archaeologist.
A brawler.
An explorer.
Too bad he became poor when he got older.
This game has everything you'd expect from an Indiana Jones adventure.
Mysterious artifacts.
Cunning villains.
Ancient discoveries.
Hard hitting action.
It's a world of constant danger where you've got to think on your feet to stay alive.
The great circle spans the entire globe.
From snake filled jungle temples to scorpion riddled desert tombs.
Stunning open areas to explore freely.
Full of secrets for you to discover.
And you'll get more than just the classic whip and revolver.
Indy's journal and his camera will immerse you in the mystery providing extra info on all of your finds so you can appreciate all of the little historical details he obsesses over.
And those details are your key to solving the ancient puzzles that hold the secrets you're after.
But ancient secrets don't come easy.
It's best to have an exit strategy.
This is an incredible new way to experience Indiana Jones and I can't wait for you to play.
When's this game coming out?
I'm looking forward to playing this one.
Doesn't that look great?
Yeah, it looks fun.
But you're probably wondering when the game comes out, right?
Yeah!
Yeah, Jeff!
December!
Wait, that's so soon!
Nice!
Indiana Jones and the Great Circle is coming out this December for Xbox Game Pass and PC.
But there is one more thing that MachineGames and Bethesda wanted to share with you about Indiana Jones and the Great Circle.
Wait, it's made by Bethesda?
Oh, for PS5!
Alright, before we wrap up O&L we do have one final game announcement for you.
Check this out!
Oh!
Last one!
Assassin's Creed?
Silksong?
Oh my god!
That's why it took so long!
They had to change the graphics!
Oh my god!
They gave the bug a knife!
That has to be Assassin's Creed, right?
Because they are saying the brotherhood.
Oh my god!
Kingdom Hearts!
Sora went to Italy!
Mafia?
MAFIA?!
Oh shit!
Mafia?!
A new Mafia game?!
Oh my god!
Sora is going to Italy!
Hahaha!
Oh!
We are going back to the roots of what fans love about the Mafia franchise.
Please be good.
I fucking love Mafia!
Mafia's success is built on our players' passion for the franchise.
And we are so proud to return to Mafia with the old country.
We can't wait to show you all more.
Thanks for watching.
Okay, that was a good...
That was good.
That was a fun surprise, right?
Alright, well that is a wrap.
I mean, at least it ended on Mafia.
We hope to see you again this December, December 12th when the Game Awards streams live everywhere for our 10th anniversary show.
Oh my god, December...
The Game Awards 10 year anniversary!
That's a really good 10 years!
Alright, well thanks again to my co-host Shox.
Didn't she do a great job?
Yeah!
Thank you so much, Jeff.
It was really great to be here.
I hope everyone had an amazing time.
Can I say something in German, too?
I don't want to show you up, but...
Vielen Dank, ihr Lieben.
Ich hoffe, ihr hattet eine super, super Zeit.
Und viel Spa auf der Gamescom.
Well done, German, as opposed to mine.
I'm learning.
Alright, thanks so much, Shox.
Thanks to everyone.
Enjoy Gamescom.
Have a great night.
How is he still learning German?
He's convinced.
He's still learning.
Hahaha!
Come on, Jeff!
See you next year!
Alright.
Honest opinion on it so far, on Gamescom.
I will rate the trailers that we saw overall, I will rate that as like I think like 6 or 5 out of 10.
There was not really a lot of good games to look forward to.
Mafia?
Yeah, Mafia.
I was like super hyped for Mafia.
The RC car in Call of Duty 6.
Hahaha!
Mafia.
Um...
I sort of forgot all the other trailers.
They were all very forget...
Hahaha!
They were all very...
I don't know.
They were all very like...
Like Space Marine, the thing is we knew about Space Marine for a long time.
They've been releasing trailers for Space Marine for fucking 2 years now.
So like it's not like...
I don't see that as a new thing.
I'm talking about like the new releases.
Not like the um...
I'm talking about the...
The TV show!
Yes, the TV show seemed really fucking hyped though.
That seemed really good.
I think my favorite part is that I was like Spelunky.
Hahaha!
So I was like Oh my god.
Spelunky got in.
I was so surprised that Spelunky is getting like an episode in the um...
In the TV show.
But other than that I don't know.
What are you guys excited about?
For me it was like... I don't know.
I was just like... I was just like looking through it and I was like...
The most memorable parts for the newer games was definitely like Mafia.
And uh...
Mafia and RC car.
Indiana Jones?
Yeah.
But like Indiana Jones...
The fact that we got a release date now...
I feel like December a lot of cool games...
Like the next couple of months...
The next couple of months a lot of like very cool games are coming out.
Um... very soon.
Um... Oh!
The...
Was it the Niki?
The Niki one was really cute.
I hope it actually...
I hope it's actually good.
Cause that game looks really really cute.
It looks like the...
The um...
It looks like their own take on like Pokemon.
Um...
I'm trying to like... There was like...
There's this game...
There's this game that like...
It was...
It was... It like reminded me when we saw the Skyworld or whatever.
The Sky game.
It reminded me of like this game... This trailer that showed up regarding like these... Like a bunch of children with like Pokemon and stuff.
Like it was like also sort of like Pokemon and they were like skateboarding and everything.
And I'm like...
I... Was it Doki V?
Was it that?
Yeah!
It was that!
What the fuck happened to this game?
I was...
What happened to this game?
It looked cool!
I heard nothing after that.
Like I thought...
It like reminded me of that.
And like...
I heard nothing about it after that.
It's been...
It's been a while.
I'm fucking gonna read this up.
Like what hap... Yeah!
What happened?
What happened to Doki V?
Like...
It was set to launch at 20... Guys!
This game was set to launch at 2024.
Like...
What happened to it?
Okay.
The official Twitter.
Cause I was like thinking about it when we were looking at that... The Niki and the Skytrailer.
The last tweet they did was 2022.
Oh god.
This game's dead.
That was...
That was... That's the...
Oh my god.
And the last...
The last update was 2022.
I was actually lowkey hyped for it.
It looked really cute.
Um...
But yeah!
Honestly like...
I don't know.
There wasn't really a lot to be excited about for this year.
This year's Gamescom.
Um... Maybe the Game Awards will have more hype news.
I don't know if it's because I'm getting older.
Uh...
Or like... Or I'm just...
I'm getting more pessimistic about game releases and stuff.
But I feel like... I feel like that... That one was like...
There was not a lot of new announcements.
Yeah.
It was just...
I was just like...
I feel like there wasn't a lot of new announcements.
It was just rehashing the same... The same trailers over... Like the same trailers we saw before.
And...
There was not a lot of like... It was all like known stuff that we knew was gonna come out.
And there wasn't really like premieres or anything.
Um... Not even for indie games too.
Uh...
So I was like not as hooked as I was.
Like I feel like Summer Game Fest had a lot more cooler stuff releasing.
Um...
And... Yeah.
But maybe the Game Awards will have... Maybe there's just too many fucking... You know what?
I know why.
There's too many fucking... There's too many like... Jeff, you made too many.
We just need two.
We don't need like one in the summer and one in the...
Like maybe like one in the summer and one in the winter.
He just made too many.
shows.
There's like...
Like there's too many shows.
And it was not as hyped anymore because there's not enough games.
There's not enough games to like fucking fill it up.
They're literally reusing the same fucking games and just use new trailers.
But it's like I know it's coming out.
Like...
Or like it's already out.
So it's like I don't have like much expectations on it.
Like...
We literally just need two.
Like summer and winter.
We don't need fucking five.
Like... It's five, right?
We have Summer Game Fest, Gamescom, the Game Awards, and like... I know there's like one more.
I forgot what it's called.
There's like one more.
There's just way too many.
Anyway...
Uh...
Oh yeah!
And then there's the Tokyo Game Show.
But that's not run by Jeff though.
Um... That's not run by Jeff.
But yeah!
Anyway...
I do have a nice stream later today at 5pm.
Um... So...
We're checking out the new Overwatch updates.
Right after I was like...
I was just like, you know...
I was just disappointed because Jeff was like, oh Blizzard hasn't been here since 2019.
And I was like, oh my god!
Are they gonna actually announce something new?
Do they actually make video games again?
And then it was just like...
Just an expansion pack.
And I was just like...
I honestly... I honestly thought they were gonna announce something new.
Cause like... Why did he hype it up?
Why was he like...
They haven't been here since 2019!
I was like... Oh?
Oh my god!
That has to be super hyped!
And then it was just... Here's some expansion packs.
And I'm like...
Okay...
Anyway guys...
It's always fun watching these with you guys.
Doing like...
Watch along...
Um...
And...
Just hang out...
Hang out with you guys as always.
Thank you all for the...
New followers and subscribers!
Uh...
The gifted subs!
The biddies!
I really do appreciate it everybody!
Uh... For those who are new here...
My name is Doki Bird and...
Um... I usually stream on YouTube!
But today I am on Twitch because I'm doing a watch along and I like to do watch alongs where I can stream the watch along itself.
The stream feed on Twitch.
So usually I do most of my watch alongs on Twitch cause it's just easier.
So please check me out on YouTube.
Uh... Usually I tweet out when I'm streaming on Twitch so please follow me on Twitter.
Um... If you want to support me via other means, please uh...
Uh... Check out my merch.
Buy my merch.
And yeah!
I really do appreciate it everybody.
As always everyone, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stood up for me, head to bed!
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!